Oh bro Ganga welcome everyone
ten years ten years
Manitoba silence ten freaking years we
did it if you don't know why I'm saying
ten years my channel just hit its
ten-year anniversary I've been uploading
consistently on YouTube for ten years I
think even longer but technically I
started pd pi channel ten years ago
amazing thank you for watching I wonder
how many of you have watched for like 10
years you literally grew up with me it's
pretty weird to think about I sometimes
see comments and people being like
alright I watched you when I was like 14
and I'm 20 now it's like I don't know
why that's so weird to me well skip all
this sappy
first I want to just I'm gonna go
through each year I want to watch a
video from every year that and kind of
see what the difference are I think it's
kind of funny to look how much has
changed over 10 years I almost at just
10 years like it's a short time or
something and I wanted to look at some
videos that I private it for whatever
reason make it maybe a bit more
interesting I found this one call of
duty black ops team deathmatch 48 for
season score I smash liked on it myself
I can't read the comments because I I
pry veted it but let's put a public
again alright what are the comments no
comments
that's so sad a ton review so that's
pretty good everyone keeps referencing
my first video as if I played Minecraft
just because it's the first one on my
channel no this is what I did I played
Call of Duty like everyone else was
doing but it was fun I said to myself
like is it a good idea to use a warlord
and you will mags with suppressor
because yeah that's really interesting
alright let's move forward it's fun but
yeah probably why people are hating on
them is because they die of them so
was I talking about the helicopter
that's how I make sense of it and they
shut it down anyway so it doesn't really
come on let's see some good gameplay I'm
curious now I think and my dog hates me
I got no feels I hate oh try to knife me
why I do wrong what am I talking about
no consistency the nuke though no
coherent thoughts I remember when I got
my to be fair though this was kind of
the style at the time I remember I
watching other people that were
successful on as Call of Duty commentary
it's the same sort of style like like
huh I said that that's weird so even
though I find it's very cringing I was
just mimicking what was popular at the
time all right first nuke
I was so excited I was screaming you
know everything I was like mom you have
to come see this she was like no all
right I'm gonna stop it right there
okay he doesn't tell me at 2010 I think
I had about 100 subscribers or maybe
something like that I remember someone
else like a big youtuber referenced in a
tweet somewhere saying like oh I
remember when I only had 300 subscribers
and I was like only 300 I'm
sitting here at 100 do you know how hard
this is like this is a long time to do
something without getting any disability
something clearly happened in 2011 let's
find out okay so this is me playing our
winni and I titled it funny that is very
funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is like the mark sample ice isn't
it the the Brad pity pot might have Brad
might say was this funny by the way I
was sitting on the floor here holy crap
I can't um I made the full circle we
moved into this place Myanmar since no
is this before maybe I don't know for
exactly when I did but I remember
sitting on the floor because we didn't
have a table it was so tiny I was like
I'm better off on the floor that's funny
full circle gamers Laura gave her life I
told you I'm consistent
I told you so let's jump to 2012 I was
at is that possible 3 million already
damn it was the time when I was in
Sweden that's why I had this video here
because look what I found
going through privates I found a video
that I made for Myers yet I would send
her videos because she'd really liked it
yeah this is to crunch dough and I don't
really want to show it but I want to see
like a little bit alright I can't I'm
sorry I know you probably want to see
more I can show with our dog family dog
at the time and the quality of camera is
the same it's incredible yeah 2013
bada-bing bada-boom
this is how many I gained it doesn't
show like it doesn't actually show like
yeah look it just so shows gain I guess
it gives you an a good idea 16 million
how's that even possible
[Music]
yeah how's it going read my name and
welcomed so now we're in Italy I moved
to mindset to Italy that was part of the
deal she stayed in Sweden for a while
and then we stay in Italy for a while it
was really fun that actually I filmed
this is so weird I can't play a tune
there it's not Friday I would never get
it on Friday did I remember I got so
much hate during this time because my
channel just blew up and that was kind
of like the cringy I mean I was never
family-friendly but a lot of kids
obviously watched me cuz I it was just
swearing constantly that was the humor
and loud noises it obviously attracted a
lot of young audience it's a lot of
people are like who's this in screechie
annoying prick so I would say between
2012 and 2013 it was one I probably had
the most fun because it was just me and
my audience and pure acceleration but
then a lot I remember like a lot of
haters would sit in and it would be I've
never dealt with that before as well so
I didn't really know I didn't have the
tools to deal with it they didn't bother
me that much but I remember it was kind
of tough because he felt like oh
everyone just thinks I'm a dumbass
cool I did it throw my life that was
pretty cool
35 years I think I just drew penis my
real name given by my mama and Dada was
Felix Felix is Latin and means happy
since the day I was born I was living up
to this name what is wrong with me why
do I draw like that nothing has changed
when it turned comes to drawing so I
could work better in Photoshop but I
also bought it to do something I had
been wanting to make for years all right
I don't want to re regurgitate is that
the right word because I talked about
this whole summary how I started already
but I just want to know like what I did
during that time so we moved to UK the
same year actually and I want to be the
best boyfriend I can possibly be
what better way to learn then go tumblr
blogs since my girlfriend isn't here I'm
gonna use this
bite their lips okay that's hilarious
this is cool oh my god first time going
to the aquarium we still go there that's
hilarious oh my god I still have that
opinion no one works in Brighton I'm
sure of it
I thought it was pretty cool and I think
you look good in like the background of
a video Hey look I bought a portal gun
guys hey remember in my millionaires
video when I said I didn't buy anything
useless portal gun right there sure you
would've bought that sure you would I
know it sucks right but I thought it was
pretty cool and I think you'll look good
in like the background of a video I have
a good girl no she bought it for me I'll
never mind
well Thank You Marcia oh that's so sweet
[Laughter]
2004 that was 2014 sorry I'm a bit all
over the place here 2015 was the year
that I totally lost it yeah I'm so
overworked I really said when you travel
I did them tour for the book we did it
see a score too high or then San
Francisco then LA gonna do more fun
tours things and you brothers are coming
along number 20
- number not number one
was it actually 21 that's funny at least
it's not in the children's chart Tyler
Oakley beat me it's not bad over here oh
that was so fun that's when we shot the
promo for that oh yeah you probably
recognized that for the TV show that was
so cool like I had fun but it was so
busy and shooting scare PewDiePie way
too fancy I don't know what I'm doing
here I'm crossing the street while
vlogging that's what I'm saying great oh
yeah because I was going on some late
night show I think it was Colbert like
30 minutes feel like I'm mushy
my network pushed me way too much I'm
signing posters so like I always had
something to do I mean fair enough like
that's their job and I could have said
no to a lot of things - oh yeah and we
were working on the game legend of the
brofist these guys were awesome like
Rufus season one we're great I think it
was in was into 2015 that I mean that I
was gonna delete my channel and I I know
I don't know if I said this before I
think I have but I was never I mean did
like haha I gotcha but the original idea
was intentional because I was just so
done I was so overworked there was way
too much and I was fed up with being so
famous like I just realized I wasn't
enjoying it I I wished it was the time
when I wish I had a smaller Channel and
no one knew who I was kind of because I
missed those times back in 2012 when it
was just like me and my audience and the
acceleration and the hype but and I felt
like I had lost time 2016 Bert about you
guys remember
so I had vlog during the time I was
shooting scare PewDiePie I should not
have done that
such a bad idea this is really the
breaking point and I really wanted it to
be like really unique vlogs and
different so cool so we're in like LACMA
as you can tell by the cool stuff I want
to show this because if we had like
really cool shot here
[Music]
like everyone's doing the same
was it cool was it cool Felix was it
cool and Brad and Michael who came with
me to LA as well hire them a big thanks
for that and I met Ethan in Ely yeah
that's right oh yeah Ethan has a really
cool trashcan I remember this 2017 what
happened in 2017 I have no idea
nothing nothing happened in 2017 I don't
remember anything I have an instan 2017
that's right love why started in 2017
[Laughter]
the most legendary show of all time
oh yeah I mean what where will you be
without love why be honest be honest
all right 2017 was just a happy year
nothing bad happened okay review every
2018 main review that's right we started
me reviews favorite show don't be afraid
Mary mortal human my dominance over you
these will definitely not aged at all
historians will study me in review they
will to understand our culture at the
time yeah alright
twenty seven twenty eighteen was a be
rough okay fine but twenty nineteen baby
that's where we came back that's when I
went from I would never have guessed
from this guy in Sweden to I'm married
this gorgeous amazing woman from Italy
gone through all these insane
experiences that I never ever would have
thought I could would would be able to
do you know going on talk shows even and
all the stuff it's kind of insane to
imagine but I feel like though as I've
done on that and done all these things I
realized at the end of it what I enjoy
doing is creating content just for my
channel
I've always prioritized that even as
busy as I've been I've always put that
number one and I'm really really glad I
still enjoy it it's kind of crazy and I
know this sounds really cringey
and cliche I think cliche is more the
word cuz I said it before but I I
wouldn't enjoy it if it wasn't for you
guys for watching I really mean that I I
still enjoy reading the comments I laugh
a lot at it some of you are funny most
of you are not most of you especially
yeah especially the spam one that says
the same thing that's comedy gold guys
well done I really enjoy those oh god
did this bump it for you guys it pushed
it out you guys subscribers no way it
did it it already has a million views
how did that happen this is the most
confusing thing
I accidentally published this thank you
for watching
preciate you subscribe only 11% have hit
the bell notification cringe new floor
gang marched out now we got a couple new
designs check it out thank you see you
guys you know in a world where science
knows no boundaries
travel to land where no tuber has been
and explore never-before-seen landscapes
they counter beings that are extinct
meet my enactors ancestors who collect
ancient items rediscover your favorite
scientifically accurate dinos what will
you create
you